you served in the us army for six years
and spent
13 months in iraq in 2008 and 9.
can you tell the story of why you joined
the army and what were
some of the moving difficult or maybe
lasting experiences from the time you
served
sure i joined when i was uh 17 years old
uh needed my parents to uh basically
sign
in order to uh to join and uh i
graduated semester early from high
school and i thought i was going to play
football in college
and kind of enroll in the spring
semester and when that didn't happen uh
basically was working at uh
chick-fil-a and quiznos had in my mind
look this is probably not the uh the
path in life that i want
um and so i knew i was gonna go to
college i knew i was gonna go play
football in the fall but i had this
window of time and so i walked into a
recruiting
office and just basically was like i'm
assuming you guys need some help
and uh yeah they gave me the whole pitch
and uh you know give you a signing bonus
you can go jump out of planes and go do
all this crazy
stuff i just said okay let's do it this
was
this was close to 9 11. this was in 2006
about five years after so what uh impact
i mean do you remember 911 what impact
did that have on your thinking about
this
so i was uh in eighth grade um if i
remember correctly
and i remember uh being in school
when it happened and uh i walked into a
classroom
and the entire class uh somebody else's
class they were all
talking to the teacher about something
the second that me and a couple other
kids walked in and got real quiet and
the teacher was like hey go back to your
like homeroom
and so it's just kind of a weird like
what's going on and then next thing i
know
they called all the students into the
cafeteria and this is back before you
know every
classroom really had a television in it
and you know cable and all that kind of
stuff
and so when we were there they basically
just said listen there's been this uh
event
that's occurred all of your parents are
gonna come pick you guys up and uh
they'll explain it to you
and so to you know a kid in eighth grade
you're basically like
what happened and so i got home and i
remember talking to my dad about it
and my dad basically gave me you know
the uh the core american
kind of talking points right look
somebody from another country came here
and tried to kill americans and was
successful in doing that
um and to some extent he just said and
i'm willing to bet you know we're going
to go back after him did that wake you
up a little bit to the idea that there's
evil out there that
you know even just the idea of terrorism
for many people that was um
when it hits you in your own land it's a
it
really shakes up your mind in some sense
world war ii
that's why world war ii was
fundamentally different for americans
than
it is for people like in russia in
england and france
and in europe in general is
there's something about when there's
families women children dying on your
own land
that's different and that was one of the
first times in america where like on
your
of course it's pearl harbor but like
this is like in recent history
it's like they hit us here
that was like a profound idea i think
america was very very good at exporting
the violence elsewhere for a long time
and uh there was this element of uh
complacency
but also this element of uh um you know
really just american superiority that
doesn't happen here right
and i think that that woke people up not
only to
um kind of the idea that other places
around the world may not like the
american ideals may not like democracy
and capitalism and and that but also uh
maybe we aren't as big tough and secure
as we thought we were
right and so obviously i think you see
the kind of over rotation with
a lot of the kind of security theater
that came after that of almost
psychologically let's make our citizens
feel like they're safe even if the
things that we're doing don't
necessarily
you know kind of change that apparatus
but on top of that i think that it
really woke people up to
uh extremism around the world and i
don't know if necessarily there was a
change in the extremism
as much as it just was an awareness
thing right how many people
you know kind of drew a line from was it
92 or 93 with the
world trade center bombing to you know
deep levels of extremism and hatred of
kind of the american industrial complex
probably not that many
2001 a lot of people and so i think that
was
you know again as a young kid you don't
understand a lot of this stuff you
basically just
hey somebody came here and tried to kill
americans and so
you know we should go fight back right
was kind of the
the response i think that i had what
role did that have
psychologically for you when you then in
2006 joined the army
i mean this is very different joining
the army than
in the time when like it's more peaceful
here you're essentially facing i mean i
don't know if you see it that way but
you know there is a war on terror and i
know that people
kind of uh criticize that whole
formulation framework of thinking but
nevertheless
you are going to iraq you are going to
afghanistan you're you're going to these
places
and are fighting these complicated like
i mean it's not even clear what you're
fighting yeah well i think there's a
couple of key pieces right so one like
one of
the actual most impactful data points if
you were or kind of stories for me
uh was the pat tillman story so i played
football uh in high school and i was
gonna go play in college
um and seeing you know this nfl player
who basically just one day
said hey i'm gonna go and do this
instead and walk away
i don't know necessarily if it was a i
want to pursue
the same story right and obviously he
ended up dying and so not exactly the
the end result that you want but i think
it was almost like uh
he made it okay if you were on a certain
trajectory in life to go take this
detour
and and to go do it but the second thing
is i was 17.
you're pretty stupid when you're 17.
you're pretty naive when you're 17 right
and so uh i almost um kind of backed
into
the deployment because i signed up uh as
a
a reserve member and so basically the
plan was to sign up for the reserves i
was going to go to basic training get
all the you know kind of education and
qualification
i was going to go to college and then
after college you know maybe there's a
chance that you will go
and serve or do whatever for me i ended
up getting deployed when i was a junior
in
college so i got pulled out of school
and so at 20 years old
uh it's not exactly what you thought you
were signing up for right especially to
kind of
leave school to go do it and then on top
of that
i probably had an advantage over most
people both on the
entry to combat and the exit to kind of
a combat situation which
was football so i always explained that
in hindsight you're in a male dominated
testosterone driven kind of combative
sport
where it's us first them and and there's
training and
and uh you know injuries and just kind
of all of the things that go into
playing a combat sport like football
to now they give you guns but you have a
uniform on still male dominated
it's just a little bit you know more
serious in terms of the injuries and
potential death and things like that but
also on the exit
from that deployment most guys i was
there with they're going back to being
you know prison guards police officers
working at the lumber yard
you know just kind of everyday americans
and so i had the fortunate ability to go
back into
kind of that combative environment go
back to play football and so it was
almost this like de-escalation on the
way out
uh where they take your guns away we
still got a uniform still male dominated
uh still combative and then eventually
you're just a normal citizen
and so i think that in some weird way i
was you know very fortunate to kind of
on the
entry and exit have that experience
where other guys didn't
you